in the shopping cart project we're gonna
look at how we can add a JavaScript
functionality to add items to the cart
as you can see first we have the button
that will gonna show the cart so we're
gonna add the first functionality to
show the cart itself and here you can
see that we have hard-coded items and
here would be a total so notice what do
we have we have two items sent and 49
again hard-coded and then we would have
$10 which obviously doesn't match the
items that we have and if we're gonna
scroll down and we're gonna see the
items then we're gonna have the little
icon that's gonna be showing up when
once we're gonna click the card icon
we're gonna have a alert that's gonna
say the item has an added to the cart
now let's add one more just so we can
see then it's for sure working so again
we have a time added to the cart and if
we're gonna scroll up first you're going
to notice that we'll have four items
right now because we're counting all the
items even the hard-coded ones but
obviously later on once you're done with
the project you can just delete the
hard-coded ones and also we have the
value so it's counting all the dollars
that we have for the items and if you
notice that we have the exactly two
items that we selected from our store
items list and they have been added to
the cart the project setup files are
located on my github so you can either
go directly and just find by the
project's name or you can follow the
link that I have left in the description
of the video once we get ahold of the
social fonts we have the folder and
within the folder as always we have all
the images the CSS that's necessary for
the bootstrap and also the font awesome
so here we can just check it out first
what we have in the index.html and so
far since there is no functionality we
can click all day long and the cart
itself is not gonna be showing and also
the items are not gonna be added to the
cart as we're clicking on the icon
because obviously this is the purpose of
the project so now let's open up the
same folder in our favorite text another
and as you can see that I'm sitting in
my index.html now I'm not gonna show
now each and every ID or class and we're
looking for because there's gonna be
quite a few of them so as we're going
along one's gonna switch back and forth
and I'm gonna show you where exactly I'm
finding the either
ID or D class so now let's right away
switch to MJS here let's make any
comment but this is gonna be a show card
so first let's start with showing the
card and also as always we're gonna do
everything in the immediately invoked
function expressions because in this
case you'll show that we're gonna
separate the issues so first we're gonna
work in our first immediately invoked
function expression we're gonna deal
with the card
and then I'm gonna create another one
which is gonna hold the items added to
the card so we're gonna make sure that
we're not sharing their global scope
with our variables so let's start with
declaring a immediately invoked function
expression which is gonna have the
syntax of parenthesis then the function
keyword then again another set of
parenthesis and then the curly braces
for the block of code will gonna be
working now here I'm going to invoke the
immediately invoked function expression
and now we're ready to start working
like I said first we would want to
select the card info which is gonna show
our card so if we're going to switch
back we are targeting this button and
after that we're targeting the actual
card so if we're going to switch back to
index HTML and we can either use the
command F so that way we can find and if
we type card info we're gonna see that
we're looking for the idea of card info
so this would be the button which we
would want to target now I cannot see
this in a smaller screen this is why
during this tutorial we're going to
switch back and forth to a bigger screen
and also we would want to show the card
so the card itself is right here so this
is below the header and here the card is
sitting now we're using the
position:absolute this is why we cannot
see the card right now and the way we're
going to do this we're going to target
the card info we're going to attach the
event listener and then we're going to
use
class of show card because if you notice
we have for the card for the actual card
that we're going to be showing the with
right now is 0 and once we click the
button we're gonna have this class of
show card to the card and then we're
going to be showing because notice that
with the show of card class the width is
18
areum's so right now the width is 0 and
overflows in this is why we cannot see
the card also and then we're going to
attach this class with a job so let's go
back to the MJS first let's name our
variable this isn't gonna be card info
because this is the same thing as we're
gonna be targeting so here we'll have a
document then we would want to use
document get element by ID and like i
said the ID was cart info so cart - info
and now once we have our object back
since we know that once we're targeting
something we're getting back return as
an object we can do event listener and
before we do an event listener let's
right away select the card itself so for
the card we're gonna have the element by
ID of cart
so the card is gonna be again the same
thing document get element by ID and
we're going to be selecting the card so
the name of the ID is gonna be the card
like I said right now we would want to
attach the event listener to a cart info
button so let's do a card info since
that is the name of the variable then
since we have the object we can use the
method of add event listener and the
first parameter we are expecting what
kind of event were listening to which is
gonna meet the click event and the
second one is gonna be the callback
function which will be executed once the
event fires and like I said we're gonna
do a very simple thing we're gonna
select the cart that we have targeted
before and we're gonna use the class
list property and then we're gonna have
a toggle now for the toggle we're gonna
specifically write what kind of class
we're gonna toggle so instead of
checking whether the cart has the class
off show cart or doesn't have we have an
option of using a toggle now for the
toggle we're gonna have to write what
class we are looking for and then
javascript is going to decide if the
cart has the class off show cart then
we're gonna remove the class once we're
clicking there in icon and then if it's
the opposite then I was still gonna be
hiding so once we save it and once we're
gonna go again to the bigger screen
because this is we're all gonna be able
to see this
once I click it notice now the cart is
showing and now we're hiding the cart
now I add a few things in the CSS it's
not just with now I also see that if
we're rotating a little bit and some
other things and obviously if you like
to you can go ahead over here and
explore what we're doing but now that we
have the cart this would be your first
thing that we would like to achieve and
the second one is gonna be working
within items now items all gonna have a
little bit more code and maybe in order
again to avoid naming the same variables
and them colliding who's gonna create
another immediately invoked function
expression so here let's call add items
to the cart so this is gonna be our
comment and then we're gonna do the same
thing well we have parentheses then we
have another set of parentheses then the
code we're all going to be placing more
code and then we're gonna invoke it
right away so again we can close it out
and we can start writing whatever
functionality would we would like now
first let's select store item icon and
what is store item icon well first I can
show you in the HTML this would be this
icon you notice here we have the cart
and it's showing only as I'm hovering
over the image of the store ID so let's
go to index.html let's write the name so
this would be store item and we have the
icon now this this would be the store
item like I said that is within the
column then here we have the card then
this would be the image then I'm sorry
this would be the actually the image
container then this would be the image
that's sitting within the image
container and then here still within the
container we're gonna have the span and
the span is gonna hold the value of font
awesome icon which would be the shopping
cart
so what we're doing is we're targeting
all of these spans with a class of store
item icon and we would want to attach
the event listener to them so here let's
do a Const we're gonna call this a cart
BTN and let's set it equal to document
and we're gonna do query selector all
because there's gonna be more than one
cart icon and then we're gonna target
again the class of store icon and we're
gonna have the store item icon sorry
store item icon so quite a long name
with a two dashes we obviously could
have maybe named it with a camel case
but let's just go along with like it is
right now so once we have selected the
store item icons then we would want to
attach the event was none before we do
that let's open up the Google developer
tools just so we can see that everything
is working and since we're gonna be
traversing a Dom a lot we will going to
be using console.log today a lot now
before we start typing all the
functionality I just want to let you
know right away that in general there is
a way better way how to do this then
what we were gonna do it and the reason
for this is this is a JavaScript Dom
project so therefore we're gonna be
traversing a Dom more than we would want
just so we can get a practice in general
going to add some kind of attribute over
here that gets hole D of the ID that's
showing and then instead of just getting
all the items with traversing the NAM
which we will gonna do in this project
you're just gonna get an ID annual is
going to contact the database and get
all the information and then place it in
the cart so this is not technically the
best way how to do it but again like I
said since this is a JavaScript Dom
project we were gonna do it a little bit
long way so let's go back over here to
have Jess and let's start working with a
cart button now like I said for the cart
button we would want to add a for each
because we are getting back a gnome list
so we wouldn't want to attach this event
listener to all of them so what we're
gonna do for each so we're gonna loop
through all of them and here for each
and one of them
have a common function where as a
parameter were passing the button that
we're looping through so each and every
element of this card mutton nodelist and
here we would want to first figure out
what we're getting at so why am i saying
is what we're getting at well I would
want to figure out what I'm actually
clicking on so instead of event listener
first let's do a BTN add event listener
and let's do BTN and event listener so
now I'm targeting the exact button each
and every time as I'm looping through
them right and now I would want to hatch
attach a click event so for all of them
we would attach a click event and here
we're gonna write a callback function
which will fire as the click event
happens so if we're going to click on
any of these card icons then the event
is gonna fire and the callback function
is gonna be the code so here let's do a
code block and now let's decide what
we're working now we passed in here the
event has the object because we were
gonna use this to traverse it down and
let's start very simple but it's view
console.log and let's do event target
now we have the event object and we also
have the property of target now the
property of target is gonna let us know
what element will click on so once I
save it and once I'm gonna go back in
smaller screen notice if I click it you
see that I'm clicking on the pie which
would be the phantasm icon however I
also have the option of clicking on the
span of the store item icon and what we
would want to do is we would want to set
up that we are reading only when we're
clicking on the actual icon on the
little font awesome icon over here
because it's gonna be easier for us to
set up the if statement that way because
we only need to care about one thing now
once we know this we know that if I
would want to set up for the icon I
would need to somehow check that the
event target has the parent element that
has this class so we know that we have
the event target however also we can use
the property of parent element
which is going to look for a parent down
and then we're gonna look for the parent
element that has the class of store item
icon so that way I'm just making sure
that only the event fires if I click on
the actual cart icon instead of
somewhere here in span so let's do again
the event target and then maybe let's
comment it out so we still have it just
in case you want to look at it and then
let's do an if statement and then like I
said we're gonna target event target
so whatever element with clicking on
then we're looking for a parent element
and we're making sure that this parent
element has a class list of store item
icon so again this way we're making sure
that the event fires only once we click
on the icon so the class list we're
gonna be looking for the class over here
now we can either grab it from here or
we can just write it so let's write a
parenthesis and we have store item and
icon so now we're gonna be firing the
event only if we're clicking on the icon
now once we have selected the icon now
the interesting part start like I said
this is gonna be a little bit a long way
but this will gonna make us practice a
traverse into them
so first things first again let's start
looking what we would need well I would
need to get somehow the source of the
image that I have right now so if I'm
gonna go back to index.html
we noticed that I have my span so the
span has the font awesome icon now the
next element right next to the span is
gonna be the image so then we need to
start traversing the Dom where once we
click the icon then we would want to
look for a parent element and then we
would want to look for previous elements
sibling so then we're looking for the
sibling what is in the Dom because if
you notice the image and the span are
both children of image container the
image container has two children and
once we know that we can select the
parent element of my font awesome icon I
know that I can select a previous
element sibling which would be sibling
right next to it and previous is
obviously because this is the first
child and
the second one and then we can select
the source but it's gonna be maybe a
little bit easier if we do it
console.log that way we can see
everything that we're doing so let me do
again a log now within this console log
we're gonna do event then we're gonna
have a target so whatever we're clicking
on then we're gonna have a parent
element and then let's have a look what
we have in a parent element so let's
save this once I click on the icon
notice that it says well parent element
class list is not actually defined so
let's go back over here and let's figure
out where is the problem now the problem
is that we have a class list that we
need to make sure that this class list
contains so we're using a property of
class list and then we're checking with
a contains so my apologies I had a
little little bug so once I click it and
again it says contains is not a function
and over here again the problem is
because I misspelled it so the name
actually is contains and hopefully with
a third time this is gonna be the charm
and sure enough now I'm getting back
this path so now I'm getting back to
span however I know that there is a
sibling for this plan which would be the
image and let me show you by attaching
one more time the property of parent
element and now let's see what we have
so we click the icon and then you notice
I'm getting the image container and the
reason for that is this is a parent
container for our span so once I open it
up notice I have the image and I have
this plan now I know how to get to the
span using event target parent element
now I would need to decide how I can get
to this image and grab the source so
let's do a previous element sibling
which would be another property so
previous previews let me make sure that
I'm actually spelling this correctly
because this is not gonna work if it's
not written correctly so element and
then we're gonna have sibling so this
would be a property name and here since
I know that this is an image all right
right away can do a source now maybe
let's before we do the source let me
just check that this property is written
correctly and once we click it
we have you seen we have the image so
this would be previous elements now like
I said arm wouldn't be interested in the
source so let me click a source and I
should be getting back the source so
once we click it we should have the
undefined because obviously again very
clever from my part and let me save this
and let me click it and sure enough now
I'm getting back to source so if I'm
gonna scroll down let's say the sweet
item I'm gonna run it and this is
showing us the sweets too so we know
we're getting back the different source
so now I would want to set it up equal
to some kind of element so some kind of
variable so first let's say that this is
gonna be let and we're gonna call this
full path so this is gonna be my
variable and let me delete the
parenthesis over here because now I'm
just setting equal to whatever getting
back to a full path now once we have the
full path there is a little bit of an
issue because you notice I'm gonna open
up a side bar I have the image but I
have the image card what is the reason
for this image card well you see when
we're going to be opening up the card I
have a smaller images I have images that
are only 50 by 50 there's no point for
me to grab this massive image and place
it in the cart so I have two sets of
images one is going to be damn a big
image that's showing within my items and
the second one is the small one that's
displayed in the cart so this full path
right now is not good enough for me I
would need only the part where it says
what kind of image it is in here because
I'm gonna change this first part you
notice I have sweets too and cupcake 1
this is what I'm interested so let me
close the sidebar and let me start
manipulating with a string that I have
back so here let's set up a new variable
and I'm gonna call this position and now
I'm going to use the variable that I
have for the full path and I'm gonna
find the position of the image of this
string of image we're gonna have a pool
full path this would be the name of my
string then I'm gonna use the index of a
method and this method is gonna help me
to find what is the position of the
image
so if I'm gonna go back and if I'm gonna
say image now I should be getting back
to image so let's do again it
console.log just so we can only see what
is happening so if I'm gonna go back and
click it on the item I should be getting
back
a 22 so I know that in full path I'm
getting back the index of 22 so index of
image is gonna be 22 now I'm gonna use
another method which would be slice so
here we're going to use the image that
we're getting back and we would be
slicing however before we slice the idea
is that I would want to take off all the
text that is including the image and
before the image because if we remember
the full path and maybe again let's
comment this out just so it's a little
bit easier to see so if we're gonna go
back refresh the page and once I click
it you notice I would want to do a slice
which would be a method that I can use
on a string and I would want to take off
all this text starting from this forward
slash so I don't want to take everything
off and then I'm gonna switch this
instead of image you notice that if we
have a card image this is the folder
that I would want to set it up for so
image card now if we see index.html
right now we're having image Suites one
now in this case we're just gonna flip
it so in the cart it's gonna be image
cart instead of this folder so let's go
back again to objects and let's change
this and the reason why I added three
these three characters because this
image is three strings long so this
string is three characters long so since
I would want to remove everything then
in this case I know that I'm just gonna
use these three characters so I'm adding
them more here and once we have the
position now let's do the slice method
and we're gonna have the slice method of
partial path so we're going to name
another variable so partial path and
we're gonna set it equal to again a full
path this time then we're gonna use the
slice and a slice would need a index so
where we would want to start removing
and then the second parameter is how
many characters however if I don't
any characters I'm gonna be taking off
everything till the end of the string so
I think it's gonna be a little bit
easier to show you so let's do again
partial path and now let's have it as a
console.log and partial path just so we
can see for sure what's happening and
once again we console.log it if I click
it I should be getting back damage now
here it says partial path is not defined
and here you can see that I added H so
let me fix that and now everything
should be working some once I click it
notice I am only getting back to sweets
or I'm only getting back the cake now
again the point for this number of three
was if I would remove it
notice what would happen so I'm gonna
save it and now once we again refreshing
once we click notice I'm getting back
the image so I'm getting the index of
the position and I can still do the
slice however I'm including the image
but since I'm gonna use the image card
folder then in this case I would want to
get rid of the image also so I'm just
gonna add again three and then I'm just
gonna be getting the name of the image
that I have so let me close the side
more and now we have the full path well
the partial path after we have gotten a
full path now over here again let's just
delete this console.log because we have
been console logging and then now let's
set up a object that we're going to be
placing in my card because if we're
gonna go back and if you notice in the
card I have the image which we just got
image so we we good with an image
however also I have the card name and
here we'll have a price so I'm gonna set
up a object that's gonna hold all these
values so first let's just call this
item and we're going to set it up to a
empty object so the object literal
syntax would be just a curly braces and
once we create a object with a object
literal we'll just gonna add a
properties to it
now obviously we can write the
properties right away as we're making
this object literal but since there is
no right or wrong way of doing it we can
just add the properties later so now
okay suppose it's gonna add key
properties later now I'm gonna call my
first property an image
now this image is gonna be equal to a
template string then I'm gonna use the
folder where I'm be getting the images
from and now I'm gonna use again the
variable since I'm using a template
string we're gonna use in the option and
then we're gonna look for this partial
path because this is gonna be the image
that we're getting back each and every
time on a different icon where we're
clicking so here let's do a partial and
we're gonna call this path again just to
make sure that everything is working
correctly let's do a console.log only in
this case let's do the item since
there's gonna be other things that we're
gonna be looking at so let me save it
and once we're gonna click on the card
notice I'm getting the image and now
this would be the path that I'm looking
for so we flipped around with an image
now we have the image card now image
would be one thing
now next I'll be looking for a elements
the name and then over here for the
price and again we're gonna have to do a
little bit of Dom traversing to get
there so here we have the console.log
item and let's just keep this item
because it's all gonna be adding the
properties later on anyway so we might
as well have it right now so let's have
it first as a name and we're gonna set
it equal to let name know name is gonna
be equal to 1
well first we're gonna start again with
a event target then we're gonna have the
parent element so we're first looking
for a parent element which would be 1
which would be span so we have a parent
element then we're gonna look for
another parent element so we're gonna
have another parent element and then
we're gonna have a next element sibling
and let me show you why we're doing it
this way so we have a another parent
element and then we'll have a next
element sibling sibling go here and for
now let's just put a semicolon and let's
console log in just so we can see again
what's happening so we have the name and
if I'm gonna click it notice what I'm
getting back so here I'm getting back
the card body and what is in the card
body well in the card body we have the
name and the dollar sign we're gonna go
back to index.html notice what happened
so we started traversing from
found awesome icon then we got to the
span which was the parent element then
we got to a parent element which was
image container now the image container
is a child of the card
now the card has also a child of card
body so I have two of them
I have image container and card body so
the same way how previously we were
looking for the image we used instead of
previous elements sibling now we're
using next element sibling so now I got
a hold of this card body now in the card
body again we're gonna be looking for
children because this text is sitting
where it is sitting within the first
child so we're gonna be looking for
eight children and then within a first
child we also have the first child of
cupcake item so store item name and like
I said let me repeat this is why we
would use a different way when we're
doing this normally but again this is a
project on JavaScript done so we'll have
to traverse the Dom so like I said now
we have next element similar then we're
going to be looking for eight children
now children is gonna return in our case
an array and I know that this is gonna
be the first child well in fact this is
gonna be the only child we're still
gonna have a node list so in this case
let's do zero so now we're selecting the
card text and then since this card text
also has a child we're looking for a
first child I was over here the cupcake
item so let's do a dot then again let's
do children and then let's have it as a
zero and here let's set it equal to text
content so that text text content you
know the text content should return us
the property now if everything goes
correctly I'm gonna save it and let's
notice what we have so if I'm gonna
click it what do I have I have the
cupcake item then if we're gonna scroll
down again we're gonna have the donut
item so I'm getting back tonight so
everything is working fine now what's
left well I would want to setup again
the item dot name so the property
and all that added I would want to add
it to the item so again let me do it the
same way where we have the item and then
we're gonna have the name so item name
this would be the property and we're
gonna set it equal tonight so both of
the properties now once we console.log
the item and maybe we can just comment
out a log off name once we click it sure
enough now we have not only the image
card we also have the name and after
that there's gonna be the price which is
gonna have a very very similar way so we
can might as well copy and paste now the
only difference we're gonna be changing
the children because remember this card
body had first a child and then let me
maybe show you in index.html notice we
had card body which we got with a next
sibling then we went to children which
would be the first child with the index
of 0 and then since we were looking for
a text with a children 0 so first child
of card text then we were gonna look
here for a children 1 so this would be
the second Indian Ovilus and therefore
will then access it with the children so
let's go back and let me just change
this so let me grab this let me just
copy and paste this however let's change
around and here first of all this is
gonna be the price so we're gonna be
looking for a price and second we're not
gonna be looking for children 1 we're
gonna be looking for a second job so
we're gonna flip this around and let's
do again income so long just so we can
see what's happening and let's
console.log the price so again scroll
down maybe to a different item and let's
see what we have so far so as I click it
now I'm getting back the value 15 so if
I'm gonna go somewhere understand again
let's click and here hoping to have it
done so we know that everything is
working however we have this dollar sign
over here and also notice that I have
the space now I don't want a space and I
wouldn't want a dollar sign so there's a
couple of things that I would need to
fix around so let's do again maybe let's
do another variable you know the
variable name is going to be final
final price so final price and this is
gonna be equal again to a few methods we
can use on the strings well first of all
gonna be selecting the string so what
string you would want well we would want
a price string where we have the value
of fifteen dollars or ten dollars in our
case then we're gonna do again the slice
so now we're gonna be slicing now since
I know that a dollar sign he is gonna be
the character of zero then the space
over here is gonna be the character one
how do you want to use the slice and if
I'm saying that starting from the first
one so I'd want to get back everything
that I have starting from the index of
one index of one is gonna be this place
and then I'm gonna be getting back to 15
now just to make sure that I have no
white space is also we're gonna add
another method which wouldn't be trim
which we're gonna remove all the extra
whitespace so instead of price let's
console.log the final price so final
price let's save this what's maybe I
don't know scroll up and down somewhere
where we have our famous cart and I'm
sure enough now I'm getting back to them
so now everything is working I have the
ten now the last thing again let's do
the same thing where we have the item
and instead of a price we're gonna have
a final price so we can do item then
price and the price is going to be equal
to a final price so again we can do the
same thing where we comment out the
final price in the console Wong and now
we're gonna be getting back what we have
the Uniting so again let's scroll
somewhere where is the first cake we're
gonna click it now I have the image the
name and the price now the price is
still gonna be the strength but don't
worry about it we're gonna fix it later
we don't need to worry about it right
now
now next on our agenda is gonna be
creating an element that we're inserting
in our cart so you notice we have a
structure over here and this is the
hard-coded part but we're gonna use this
so we have the element we have the name
then we have the price and then we have
the icon that's going to be used later
on not in this tutorial but
to delete this let's go back and let's
figure out what we're doing well first
of all we need to see what's happening
well we have the log some log is fine
maybe we can just comment it out so it's
not in my way and now we would want to
create a new item and what kind of item
we're going to be creating well if I'm
gonna go back and I'm gonna look in the
nav bar where I have my items then I
should notice that first I have the card
info which was a mutton and then I'm
gonna look have to look for the card and
our oldest here I have the card so we
selected the card and this would be the
card item now this is the div that we
would be creating now we're gonna be
using a template string so we don't have
to recreate everything that's the good
thing of coding this in the HTML that
now with the template strings we can
just reuse a lot of things and just
change the values over but I would first
need to create that div so let me go
back in the app jas and let me first
create a div so const then we're gonna
have card item so this would be the name
off alright um and we're gonna do a
document create element so we're gonna
be creating an element and we're gonna
be creating a div now since you noticed
that within a div i have what i have few
of the classes over here so first let me
just grab this whole div with a whole
comments and everything now we're going
to be deleting them later but for now we
should just have it and here let's do a
template string so let's set it up over
here like a template string and then let
me just copy and paste this because we
will gonna be reusing this so now like I
said I have the div I'm gonna be
creating a class list so I'm gonna
select the same thing card item then
we're gonna use a class list since I
would want to add these classes because
even though I'm creating a div I still
want to add these classes now for the
class list we can just rewrite the same
thing so we found one a card item and we
write over here that I would want card
item then we can do comma then the next
one is gonna be D flex and after that
we're gonna have a justify content and
between them I'm just making sure that
I'm not missing something because it's
going to
painful to look for mistakes text
capitalized and as you already know if
you're watching my tutorials I'm quite
infamous for making mistakes like that
with a misspelling and the last one is
gonna be my three so these are the
classes that we're having now again like
I said we were going to be using
template strings ourselves so we don't
need to retype everything I can just
delete these comments because I don't
need them in the template string and now
I can just use a inner HTML and I can
set this to it to the inner HTML so
first let me close this and now I can
say that I would want for the card item
and I would want to set it to in inner
HTML so we're gonna have the dot of
inner HTML and we're gonna set it equal
to the same template string so again
maybe let me just save this so that way
it's gonna be a little bit better format
so notice now I created a card item I
added all the classes that I had in my
div they already hard-coded in my HTML
and next I just used the inner HTML and
everything
that was already in my HTML I just
applied in my objects because I can use
the template string I can directly place
whatever HTML I have so now the last
thing that I would want is just change
the values because obviously I don't
want the hard-coded values we're gonna
have a dollar sign then remember the
item that we created the object that's
holding all the values every time that's
changing as we're clicking on a
different item now we're gonna use that
item so first we're gonna do item image
since we're looking for the image then
we're gonna look for a name so where's
the name so here's the price and we
should have somewhere a name so we have
again I cannot find a name for some
reason okay because it's sitting so
sneakily over here so let's delete this
and again let's use a dollar sign in
this case let's do item and this would
be the item name and the last one is
gonna be the item price so again another
sign and we're gonna be targeting the
item and the price so now we have
created this car item now the last thing
that's left is to target the cart
remember we have the card so the items
are sitting within the card and then I
would want to insert this in the card
however we're not gonna do the append
and the reason for that is notice I have
the item I have the item and then I have
the total so if we're going to use the
method of appending the child then these
items are going to be somewhere here in
the bottom so instead we need to use the
insert before so let's go back again and
let's figure out what we have so we have
the happiest and like I said we have the
you know HTML now once we are done with
inner HTML maybe let's do a comma where
we have a select cart and now we would
want to select the card so let's create
a variable
this is gonna be card document get
element by ID the ID is gonna be the
card then we're gonna have another
variable with a name of total so we're
gonna have Const total and here we'll
then use a query selector document query
selector and then the di the ID no not
the ID the class is going to be card
total container and I'm gonna show you
in a second where I'm getting this from
container and once I have selected like
I said we're going to use the method of
inserting before so I'm gonna use cart
since we're selecting the cart then the
method name is gonna be insert before so
let's go down and let's use insert
before
I'm insert before is gonna use two
parameters first is gonna be what item
we would want to insert so we would want
to insert the cart item and then we
would want to say where we would want
insert before we tried so here we're
gonna use the total now let me save this
and let me show you where I'm getting
back to total and only if I'm gonna go
down we have the cart item card and now
notice we have the cart total so the
point of this I want to insert before
the cart or total so the card total is
gonna be all the way in the bottom now
maybe the last thing just show the
customer that everything has happened
correctly we're going to do add the
alert
obviously we could probably name
something here better within the HTML it
would be nicer if we would have some
kind of element showing up over here but
for the sake of this exercise let's just
do alert and if some of you are annoyed
by an alert you can obviously go ahead
and create your own element or your
enjoy and let's do item added to the
cart so I'm just gonna use one of those
alert boxes so if everything works
correctly
we're gonna go back we were gonna have
items in our cart so let's go back let's
refresh and let's scroll down so we're
gonna have a sweet item now in the sweet
item has the cart now once I click it
something is wrong something is not
working because I don't have my alert so
again let's figure out where is the
issue so either we're targeting
something wrong or there is some kind of
mistake somewhere so again let's check
it out what we have in the console and
let's check it out on the smaller screen
because and here it says cart item class
list is not a function so let's figure
out where we have the issue so we have a
cart item class list and this is not a
function and here instead of class list
we'll just need to have add so again my
apologies we have the class list
property and then I'm going to be using
the method of ADD so we would want to
add these classes over here and you see
this is the nice thing about console and
log so we know for sure what we're
getting back because we can do all this
code and then start scrambling for the
answers where is an issue so again my
apologies I should have added a method
of that and then here the paradigm
parameters are all the classes
we're adding to the cart item so let's
go back let's refresh and hopefully
everything works fine this time so once
I click it it says the item has been
added to the cart again let's scroll
down let's maybe do the sweets again
let's click it and says that it's added
to the cart now let's grow up and the
moment of truth sure enough we have the
sweet item which was 5 bucks and then we
have the another sweet item which was 15
well that wee little bit suspicious so
again maybe let's do a cake maybe let's
do
now the other cake maybe let's do a
Dolman this time so now I have all these
items so let's go up and everything is
working fine so once we have figured out
how to work within items there's one
more thing that we would want and we
won't want to display what is the total
so the money total that we have and then
we would want to display how many items
so let's go back again to our app is
let's scroll down and after dealer let's
call this function let's say that this
functions name is gonna be show totals
however I'm not gonna write this
function right now I'm not gonna write
it within this event listener so here
we'll just gonna call this function once
we have added the items how are we gonna
go all the way in the bottom so still
within our immediately invoked function
expression however all the way in the
bottom so after the event listener and
let's write the function so let's write
that we would want add totals so show
totals and let's maybe start very simple
let's say that has a function then show
totals unless just console.log and just
for sure we know that everything is
working because again we don't want to
spend another 10 minutes writing
something and then scrambling for the
answers so hello and once we save it if
everything is correct we should have a
console log of hello so once we open it
up and it says the alert
you've seen the alert runs we're adding
items in the cart and here would meet
hello so now we know that we have the
function so now we just need to figure
out the functionality of the function
then let's start first by creating an
array that's gonna hold the total of my
hours and how we're gonna do this well
we're gonna set up again a query
selector all so I'm gonna be looking for
all these prices you notice I have the
price price and all these prices now we
will gonna be still counting whatever we
hard-coded Oriya because this just makes
sense now obviously if you want you can
just go ahead and delete them for now
since you already have all the items you
have all the structure and everything
but we're all gonna be still counting
them so each and every time we're gonna
be still counting them now we're not
going to count
as we refresh the page because we
haven't set up anything in a local
storage but as we add the item we will
going to be getting the correct total
and the way we're going to do this we're
going to create an empty array then
we're going to select all these prices
and then we're going to loop through
them and then we're going to add them to
an array and then we're going to use the
reduce function to get one value and
then we're gonna do the same thing for
this value so let's go back again and
let's like I said first create an empty
array so Const total now this is gonna
be empty here but it's gonna be an array
then let's look 40 items so the items
and the items like I said is gonna be
document then here we're gonna be
looking for a query select all since
there's gonna be more than one we know
that we might be getting I don't know 20
values and the class name is gonna be
card item price now again let me show
you where we're getting back and let me
make sure that I have the dot so that
way I know that everything is working so
let's save this let's look at index.html
notice we have the ID of card item price
and the class notice this is the item
and here this will be the price so we're
using the query selector oh to get all
the prices so let's go back to the
objects now once I have the items then I
would want to loop through them so items
for each so as I'm looping in the
callback function we're gonna write what
we would want to do with each and every
item so the item is gonna be passed as a
parameter and now we're gonna say total
so the array that we have and we can use
the push method and we can add the item
text content and while we're getting the
text content because the text content is
gonna be holding the value know R so
this is the hard-coded value as we're
inserting them with our own JavaScript
this is they happening dynamically so I
cannot show you right now you can just
see it here so this is what we're
looking for now let's go back but the
problem is that this is a text value
whatever we're getting back from text
one content is going to be the string so
we also would need to use a method of
parse flow which is gonna
take a string and set it as a math
operation basically it's gonna set it as
a number now first let's do text item
text content that we're getting back on
and let's just count so log it just so
you can see that what I'm saying makes
sense so log and let's do total just so
we can see what we have in a total so
once I'm gonna refresh it in full scroll
down and once again click on the item
we're gonna say you see we have 1099 299
so hard coded values and the value that
we add but you notice we have a
quotation marks so it is a string so now
let's do a parsed flow so that way we're
making sure that this is gonna be the
number so parse and float and since this
is a method we're gonna add this item
context content in the parenthesis and
now in our case if we're gonna scroll
down again we're gonna look for the
value I'm gonna click it again we're
going to add it and now we have the
numbers so this is what we want so
everything is working correctly now here
we can again maybe comment out a total
and let's keep on working now let's get
a total money so let's do a connoisseur
new variable total money now for the
total money this is gonna be equal to a
total so the name of our array and we're
gonna have it as a total reduce and
we're gonna use the reduced function now
for tea I'm sorry method so for the
reduced method we are looking for a
callback function this is gonna be
called however the reduce method
callback function requires two
parameters so the first one is gonna be
the total or accumulator and the second
one is gonna be the current or in our
case is gonna be the item so the total
is gonna be what we are returning at the
end of the reduce and the item is each
and every item as we're looping through
because even though this is a reduce
we're still looping through all the
items that we have in total so let's go
back and let's just add a curly braces
and remember that with a reduce we need
to have an initial value so since I'm
going to be using numbers
set it as a zero now what we're going to
write in a code block
well first we always need to remember
that we need to return the total
otherwise we're not gonna get our
accumulated value and once we have
returned a total knowledge is do what
we're doing each and every time as we're
looping through well it's gonna be very
simple we're gonna say total so total
whatever we have and just plus equals so
we're adding we're not rewriting each
time and then we're just gonna say item
and then once we have the total money
again we can just find out what is
happening so in our case let's do a
console log and let's call this total
money since this is a name of our very
move and notice that something's wrong I
have one one I not money so let's save
this and if everything is working
correctly let's add one value and let's
add another value I'm getting the totals
however there is an issue you notice
we're using the floats and using floats
is nice we could have used the parson
integer and then we wouldn't get these
however let's imagine that whatever
store will going to be using they were
all going to be using some kind of sense
not every store is gonna have the
numbers so we could have used the parse
int instead of float but it is better
for using the flow I purposely use the
phone
and we need to fix this somehow we don't
want to show in a card these kind of
ridiculous numbers and the way we do
that and again we're gonna do the new
variable so counts final money and we're
gonna set it equal to a total money so
the variable that we have right now and
we're gonna use another method and the
method is gonna be two fixed now for the
fixed we need to pass the parameter so
how many numbers after the dot in my
case I'm gonna use two and then we just
can do instead of total money let's have
it as a final money save this and now
let's add again a few items over here
let's add one to the cart and notice I
have 30 198 instead of these ridiculous
ten numbers behind the knot and now we
have 36 so everything is working now the
last thing what's left
just insert these values so if we're
gonna go back what I'm trying it to do
is insert the value over here in the
total and insert the value on the top
and we're also going to use the items
and here this is gonna be very simple
who's gonna get the length of an array
so who's gonna see how many items we
have and then these would be D items
there's our display now let's go back
and let's just target these and then
once we have target in them we just
would want to insert the final money so
here it's gonna be very simple let's do
a document and there's gonna be
documented by ID document query selector
and another ID so that's last thing
document get element by ID I'm looking
for the cart total and I'm gonna show
you all these values right now I just
type them first and then we're gonna see
where they're at so text content is
gonna be equal to a final money so the
final money I want to show like I said
we'll get a copy and paste this because
a lot of things are gonna be the same
then we can do the item count so this is
gonna be another ID and we're looking
for and here the text content volge is
gonna use like I said the array length
so if we want to show how many items we
have the only thing we need to show we
we know that we have the array that's
holding all the values so let's do total
length since I know that this is going
to be referencing how many items I have
dinner right and last thing the final
money text content however here we're
gonna be looking for item total so the
class of item total and since I'm using
the class I would need to change this to
query selector and now let's go in the
index.html I'm gonna show you where I'm
getting all this admit your show let me
just fix this query so out there let's
save this now if we're gonna go back to
index.html now first things first let's
scroll down to a total so car total so
what I'm looking for you notice I have a
clear card and check out however the
cart total is the one that's holding the
total so this is why an app GS we were
targeting the element by ID of cart on
now the second one is going to be where
we go up and this is going to be the
info so again we're gonna scroll
somewhere this would be in the card
we are too low notice we have the card
info and then again we have the item
total and like I said this would be in
the class this why we have the class and
therefore we're using the ID now let me
see yeah item total I'm using the class
so everything is correct however for the
item count there has to be an ID so let
me just check that it is an e so item
count item yeah the ID is item count so
now we know where we're getting all the
values and the last thing is just to go
and refresh and hopefully everything
works fun like I said these are
hard-coded values so obviously we would
be probably putting 0 on 0 but I just
wanted to put something like 2 items in
10 49 or whatever now let's scroll down
and again let's maybe add like six items
just so we know that everything is
working correct another this guy another
this guy and let's do another this guy
now everything is working fine let's go
up and sure enough we have the value of
56 do we have six items yes we do so one
two three four five six and I'm now
going to take my calculator out but I
think that this should be a correct
value if not obviously correct me